Okay, guys,
Gremlins 2 .
I'm telling you,
this movie...
[door opens and closes]
- Should write itself.
The first one was a classic.
This should be
pretty straightforward.
Basically, all we're doing
is maintaining the integrity
of the original picture.
We want to do
all the stuff with the water
and the--
What--
Uh, can we help you?
I'm sorry.
Let me introduce myself.
Hi, y'all.
My name is
Star Magic Jackson, Jr.
I'm the Hollywood
sequel doctor,
so studio just brings me in
to oversee things
when they about
to drop a deuce.
So that's why I'm here,
but don't mind me.
I'm just gonna be over here.
Y'all do your thing.
It's your movie.
Okay.
Let's brainstorm.
Adam.
If it's gonna take place
in an office building,
I was thinking,
what if Gizmo gets wet
from a water cooler this time?
Okay, hold on a second!
I'm sorry, I'm gonna have
to step in here.
Just one second,
sweetheart.
So what's wrong
with y'all?
Y'all are looking like
a bunch of sad sacks.
This is G2, people.
We writing Gremlins 2.
It should be a party,
with pizza and anchovies,
pineapple.
Just come on.
Lift up the spirits.
Look, okay, I'm gonna
put a little bit of spice
into the mixture here.
What if we did this?
Everybody here gets
to design their own gremlin.
Um, I-I don't see that
the gremlin design is broken.
It's called brainstorming,
not brain drizzling, sweet pea.
Okay?
Shut your mouth
for a second.
(Star)
Look, here's the thing.
None of this is final.
So you mean, like,
what if there was,
like, a brainy gremlin?
[scoffs]
A brainy gremlin?
You talking
about a gremlin with glasses
who could talk
and sing New York, New York?
That's brilliant.
It's in the movie--done.
[upbeat electronic music]
Whoa, whoa, you said
that nothing was final.
That was before I heard
the words "brainy" and "gremlin"
in the same sentence together.
It's done.
I love it.
It's in the movie.
Next.
What about
a, uh, spider gremlin?
You mean a gremlin
with eight legs and a thorax,
just catching pretty ladies
in a web in an office building?
Oh, my God,
it's in the movie.
I love it!
Next!
- What about a bat gremlin?
- [gasps]
You mean a gremlin
with leathery wings,
just flying around,
flip-flopping,
bust through a wall,
make a perfect bat symbol
in the wall,
get outside,
get in some wet concrete,
jump up on a building,
and just dry in place
like a gargoyle gremlin?
We are cooking
with gas now.
I love it.
It's in the movie.
Next.
Could there be
a female gremlin?
Just lipstick, boobies.
Bitch, you had me at
"little gremlin va-jay-jay."
I love it so much
that it's not only in the movie,
but it's definitely
in the movie.
There's no backsies on that one.
No penny taxies.
Yes, yes, yes!
In the movie, done!
That's why need a woman
in the writers' room.
Next.
I don't know.
A googly-eyed gremlin?
But you do know,
because you're talking
about a gremlin
whose sole purpose in this film
is just that he looks
stupid as fuck.
Yes, it can be
in the movie,
and it is in the movie.
Done. Next.
What about you, silver fox?
Um, electricity gremlin?
You just said noun
and "gremlin,"
like you're playing
Mad Libs.
You just like a child.
You have the brain
of a child.
You do not have
a high IQ,
but you haphazardly
came up with a gremlin
that's just made out of bolts
that is zigzagging
all over the room,
and it's done
completely in animation.
You a crazy person,
and your idea's
in the movie!
Done. Next.
Can we put
the Hulkster in it?
What?
You talking about
putting Hulk Hogan,
professional wrestler
turned actor
turned cultural icon
in the movie,
where he break the fourth wall
of the movie he's in
by talking to the audience.
You, sir...
are a raging psychopath.
Don't let this town
take that away from you.
That's it.
I don't even care anymore.
We got the Hulkster
in this bitch,
so it's done.
I don't have
any more time,
so let me just recap
right now.
It's brainy gremlin,
spider gremlin,
bat gremlin, lady gremlin,
googly-eyed gremlin,
electricity gremlin,
Hulk Hogan's
gonna be in the picture.
I'm gonna throw in
a gremlin myself.
Vegetable gremlin!
Just write it up.
- I'm having so much fun.
- Why not?
Thank you, it's all gonna
be in the actual film.
Now I got to go
put some cowboys
in Back to the Future III.
Sayonara, y'all.
Ooh!
[applause]
Now, okay,
you guys know
that none of that is gonna
be in the actual movie.
[upbeat electronic music]